reggie miller calling the western
conference finals in
orlando alongside brian anderson chris
weber ali leforce game three
lakers nuggets that'll be uh tomorrow
night at nine
eastern lakers win it last night at the
buzzer
let me start at the end of that game
what were the nuggets
trying to do supposed to do and how'd
the ball end up in anthony davis's hands
reg
well before that last shot i'm going to
give the nuggets a lot of credit
because initially after
uh the joker had scored and had put the
nuggets up one
that possession when it was you know 15
or 20 seconds left
on the shot clock that play was for
lebron james when he was isolated up top
one-on-one he drove to his left
kicked it out and they got into that
scramble situation which ended up with
jamal murray
blocking green shot that put
2.1 left on the clock that initially was
great defense by the nuggets so with 2.1
left on the clock
um you know if you're michael malone
there's not a lot of time to do
too much maybe one dribble go up so i
think his
thinking was let's protect the rim
no allyou so you put a big on the ball
which was jokage
and you put another big in the game who
guarded anthony davis which was mason
plumlee
this is where the problems happen
because
what we saw was a lack of communication
on the nuggets part when anthony davis
came off
a brush screen with lebron james it
should have been a switch between mason
plumlee and jeremy grant you see those
lack of communications
if you we were playing in a normal
situation they would have been playing
in the staples center
with 20 000 screaming fans if you can't
hear
you know you're trying to communicate to
your teammate
um but in a bubble situation total
breakdown because
that was either supposed to be a switch
jeremy grant taking anthony davis
as he brushed off lebron or mason
plumley
as we call it trailing locking and going
and staying
on the hip of anthony davis he goes
plumly to the body of lebron jeremy
grant stays with lebron and anthony
davis is wide open 43.
i will say this i give the joker jokic a
lot of credit because remember
he was guarding rondo out of bounds and
he gave a
valid effort in trying to contest that
shot but it was just it was too wide
open for a.d
imagine if a.d doesn't hit that shot
what are we saying today about that game
i think it would have been a collapse by
the lakers because they were in control
of that game
pretty much the whole way i give the
comeback kids a lot of credit
denver they've been the one team
especially during these playoffs when
they've been down double digits have
found a way to get back in ball
games but if if we're fifths
anthony davis hits the shot um and it's
a crushing blow
for a young team that has battled back
all the way yogic was finally the same
yolkitch we saw
in that clipper series where he
dominated uh the paint area
um but it's tough loss for the nuggets
because they easily could have evened up
this series at 1-1
i think that the talking heads media
critics would have been
all over lebron that he didn't take the
last shot if anthony davis takes the
shot
and misses the shot then you know what
the reaction is going to be reg
oh why isn't lebron taking the shot here
well i think lebron is always going to
make the right play
and the right play on the initial drive
was right because he collapsed the
defense and kicked it out
and they got into the scramble situation
but
of course lebron is always going to be
the you know
the focal point of what people want to
say towards the end of games but
the lakers are up 2-0 anthony davis and
by the way i know we're in this bubble
situation
how about some of the game winners that
have gone on down here
from devon booker versus the clippers
luca and his game winner versus the
clippers
og and inoby you know that he tied up
that
and re-change that series um and then
last night ad with the game winner at
the buzzer
it shows you yeah they're in a bubble
and they're they don't have their fans
in front of them
but the play and the shots have been
unbelievable down here what was your
reaction to lebron
publicly saying that uh he was po'd
that he uh only got 16 first place votes
for the mvp
so is he is he more upset that he didn't
win
mvp is he conceding that okay maybe i
shouldn't have won mvp
but i certainly should have gotten more
first place votes which it kind of
sounded like
um look that's a heck of a list to be on
i know he's
been runner-up four times along with
larry legend
um i think it was more so for him to
kind of get him going which he kind of
showed last night
he had 12 of the first 14 points for the
lakers and 20 of their first 40 and then
he kind of
tapered off after that i think this was
more for lebron to kind of get him going
throughout this uh series and the rest
of these playoffs
wait do you think that he's
manufacturing this that he's because he
wasn't the mvp during the regular season
no he wasn't it was giannis but i think
this is
uh michael jordan move you know trying
to find something to kind of motivate
you
and get you going get his teammates
pumped up
and uh because he wasn't the regular
season mvp and people need to
understand the distinction between the
two because giannis had an unbelievable
career
if you're picking a franchise in the
team who you're gonna pick
obviously you're gonna pick lebron james
because you know
the finished product and you know what
he delivers for your team
but in terms of numbers and mvp
i voted for you honest giannis was my
mvp yeah i i didn't
i i guess he might have been upset that
it wasn't close at all
and look lebron was a great story this
year and as we've talked about
part of this vote or the thought process
is always what is the good story
when charles won the mvp when carl
malone won an mvp
they were a fresher story than michael
jordan i voted for jordan
every year because i just thought that
he is the most valuable player in the
league
and he's going to win a championship and
i would vote the same way with lebron i
always looked at him he's he's like
jordan that he's the most valuable
person in the nba
and he's going to play for a
championship maybe that's not
you know fair to do it that way but i
didn't go out of my way to go boy i'm
kind of bored with voting for the same
guy
how about i mean greek freak was a great
story last year
he wasn't the same story this year i
thought lebron
was a better story that didn't mean he
was the mvp but
i probably would have leaned that way to
vote for lebron
to do what he's doing and he completely
reinvented the roster made anthony davis
the focal point
led the league in assist and he did it
in the western conference where people
said well let's see what lebron would do
if he played in the western conference
so
from a story line that was a better
story than the greek freak
and also theodore i i think if you ask
lebron deep down
um he's trying to do something that no
one's
ever done in the history of the game and
that's when
three championships with three different
organizations
and winning finals mvp no one's ever
done that
um he's done it twice obviously with
miami and cleveland and he has a chance
to do that
with the lakers obviously he would
probably be battling for that finals mvp
with anthony davis but he has an
opportunity
to do something michael jordan's never
done
larry bird kareem abdul-jabbar um
kawhi leonard is on that track he has a
shot to do that but obviously he lost
this year to win finals in vp for three
different teams
but i think yeah he's probably
disappointed that he didn't get enough
first place votes
this year behind giannis but i think in
the back of his mind
he has bigger goals which is winning
number one winning the championship for
the lakers
which would be his fourth but winning
finals mvp as well
yeah i think that he he's trying to
create something the same way jordan did
i totally get it
um and for him to kind of put it out
there publicly
you know that and people said all you
know sour grapes
you know that uh i don't think so i
don't
i don't think that i would say more so
it's it's a rally cry for his teammates
for them to kind of pick up for them to
see
you you call it manufactured that he's
upset about it
but when they see that they kind of want
to rally around him and play better for
him
for him to get into a situation where he
can win a fourth championship
reggie miller joining us from the bubble
you've got game three lakers nuggets
that'll be tomorrow night
at nine eastern are people gathering to
watch the nfl
like what when you're in the bubble did
you get together with anybody to watch
football yesterday before your date
i didn't social distancing um
our hotel i would say is less than 50
capacity full and a lot of people they
do have tvs going down in the lobby and
stuff but a lot of people aren't
gathering i think they're doing the
smart thing and
staying in their rooms and and watching
it um
but in the comforts of your room you get
a chance you have the clicker you can
you know go through all the you know the
games and you have
on your yeah but it's kind of sad you're
by yourself
in your room you're right it's not the
same but
you know you can kind of like for me
yelling at the t the television on that
you know atlanta you know
see to me how does that that happens at
a college game that may happen
it certainly happens in a high school
game that cannot happen
at the professional level it's plays
like that they get coaches fired
the next day because to me it looked
like the falcons
had no idea what the rules were on that
onside kick
that they could just fall on the ball at
any time that's just me
i don't look i i profess i love football
but i'm a fan of football but for me
that was my observation
they did not know what the rule was you
know it's like j.r smith not knowing
how much time time is left in the
closing moments of the game and you saw
lebron's
look at him right yeah if i'm the rest
of those guys
i'm looking at the guys on the on the
football field like
fall on the football
come on man that can't happen that
cannot happen the uh celtics and heat
uh with the uh heat up two games to one
uh what do you like in the you know
celtics that they had to win this game
after yelling and screaming and throwing
stuff in the locker room and they came
out and played great but
uh handicapped this series i still like
miami to win this series i still think
it's going to go
the full distance i think the
celtics got a you know a shot of energy
when gordon haye would come back because
now you have another playmaker
another ball handler a guy who can make
shots
and can guard multiple positions and
he's coming off the bench
versus second line players on the heat
so i i think that's a plus
this is going to go seven if you look at
the numbers through the first three
games
you would say boston clearly should be
up three nothing in this series because
they've played that well
miami has just found ways to win because
of that bulldog mentality
that's why i believe it's going to go
seven games
i think jimmy butler has been good he
hasn't been great and
game four could be one of these games
where he could put an imprint on both
ends of the floor
of being great to try to get this heat
team up 3-1
but the way tatum smart and now
jalen brown has to me
i mean that's just a three-headed
monster now the way jalen brown has been
playing at both ends of the floor
so who do you think the lakers won
they probably would want boston just for
the simple fact
boston has 17 championships the lakers
have 16.
this is a chance for them to tie the
the celtics the historic celtics in
terms of championships
um but well the museum you're saying who
did the lakers want it's not over yet
because we said that about the clippers
you said that about the clippers no no
no they were the clippers this is
different oh
shots fired no they've been fired they
were fired along
they haven't stopped being fired you
know are they going to have like
get-together like picnics to improve
their chemistry with the clippers
what are they thinking looking at these
conf
looking at the rusher conference finals
i mean it's
this has got to be gut-wrenching for
them i would say
if at all they're watching it they're
probably not even watching it it's
probably too painful
to watch what are you doing the rest of
the day
i'll probably get a workout in and then
get ready for monday night football
there's nothing to do here we're in a
bubble
theodore at least you guys could come on
down and visit me
[Music]
i don't there's nothing to do what
danette do you want down there because i
can send one down there just to keep you
company
i would probably seaton
what are you come on down dude let's
roll
i'm in yeah but reg seton wants to go to
the bar and you don't
go to the bar okay well he's out
holly paulie come on you're my boy
i don't ride bicycles and i can't shoot
threes okay no polly
um mclovin
hey you and i we could like hang out and
play some uno or something
oh i do like uno but i don't want to be
a third choice move on
yeah how do you think fritzy feels he's
fourth choice
christy what happened we were boys i'm
the last choice no you you don't want
freaking i just want to walk around in
my towel in the hotel meeting a lot of
chinese food and drink a lot of
mountains
oh that's not good yeah fritzy comes in
and he sets his towel down and he'll sit
on your bed
that's way too much mo mane and mountain
dew yeah that's all he needs
uh all right well uh thank you reg we'll
talk to you soon
have fun uh tomorrow night dance i would
take you guys all
down i wouldn't all right equally that's
uh the hall of famer turner sports nba
analyst game three
will be tomorrow night lakers nuggets
tip off nine eastern on
tnt